I look beautiful
hey
any one of you moves she dies okay if
anyone comes near me they stand
okay okay let's not fight let's not
fight let's not fight I give up okay I
give up
Jesus Christ
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
am I a psychopath
you know what this is too op I'm not
gonna use this
oh
whoa
Meg
hey
[Applause]
I'm coming
okay
I'll run like a gorilla
there we go
look she's waving at us don't you feel
better now oh sorry sorry oops what is
this oh
come back
yes
don't ever not fly okay that's too op
let's try this up again this is my
bridge [ __ ]
from your legs
a week and he's weak
[Music]
he'll never get me alive
and I'm like Wolverine
your spouse
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
oh no now she can walk
your defenseless against the Viking
Jutsu
no no
don't judge me okay this game very
immersive
whoa
so evil
whoa
whoa ah
oh look at me
what am I gonna do now
yeah smell it kiss it
[Music]
this is so horrible I'm just punching
women harassment is not a game
bullyhunters.org
you dumb [ __ ]
oh god what happened to your face
whoa
holy [ __ ]
Stars
okay Boomer yeah
foreign
she's still alive she's just in shock
don't worry child
subscribe it's a pretty bad [ __ ]
there you go what's wrong with me
[Music]
oh
yes
here your turn
your turn
can you get canceled for leg I don't
think so
[Music]
what is this
whoa wow
[Music]
drop it drop the weapon
I want that
damn it
stay down stay down
no no Bam Bam don't do that is he alive
he's lying he's alive he's alive we got
one we got him stay
what are we going to do with you huh
hey let me drink bro
yes yes
now we fight like a man
yeah you want some
can you guess
[Music]
[Music]
listen to me
whoa bro bro sorry
no bye [ __ ] God damn it oh this game is
too much fun man it's weird whoa
I mean blood loss
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
yeah
please don't do this man
fine you leave me no choice
thank you
oh God oh God oh God what am I doing
bro you okay fine
oh